We're monsters who help,
and we call ourselves the Helpsters!
It's a delight to see you,
but I'm afraid I have a problem.
Problems are our specialty!
If there's a way, we'll find it
Just have to monstermind it
From the makers of Sesame Street.
Our goal is to teach Wayne a magic trick
so he can become a magician.
We just need a plan.
I believe there's an idea
inside each and every one of you.
-What's happening?
-What? I don't get it.
He's getting an idea.
How can we help you?
'Cause all we wanna do is help you
For problems big or small...
Let's get this done.
...they're here to help solve them all.
Everything is under control.
Everything is out of control!
Come quick!
High fives and handshakes
Oh, no. We got it wrong!
We are Helpsters,
and nobody's giving up,
not on my watch.
What a difference a plan makes
High fives and handshakes
Bravo!
We did it, everyone!
Let the jubilations commence!
-What?
-That means "be happy."
Helpsters
Watch now on the Apple TV app.